[Music]
who here is uh terry crews fan i like
talking to her he's a really nice guy
kim the boss guy you met him yeah yeah
well he i know he's the pastor local
this guy oh that was arcadia this is
arcadia but i thought you don't know
[ __ ] about pasadena apparently that's
the one thing i do know that's why he's
won he clearly doesn't know because
i've seen him stand outside of the
cheesecake factory at san diego why is
he standing with his boobs bouncing did
you ask him where he lives he was making
youtube videos about being addicted to
jacking off the porn remember i was
addicted to porn yeah
i mean who isn't
did you watch them
what do you hear about a story like i
gotta jack off something so terry crews
uh
says and claims the reason why he got so
strong and buff was because check it off
was because he considered killing his
abusive father hey that's like me
but i didn't get buffed though
it was not like you then
i revenged in a different way
so he recently was on a a podcast called
the diary of a ceo
uh and he opened up about his traumatic
childhood where the 53 year old
literally talks about his alcoholic
father uh and how his father used to
abuse his religious mother
and he once witnessed his father terry
crews senior knock out his mother
patricia even though he was a junior
yeah
the actor said a lot of my desire to be
strong was because i knew one day i may
have to kill my father because he was
just that person
he added and it was intense man i guess
it was a very very intense upbringing
and i became this person who just wanted
to keep the peace because anything to
keep the peace i became what you would
call a pleaser and it was a lot of work
because i lost all uh all my like who i
was it was dependent on who was around
and i was all sudden to be what they
wanted me to be
so literally
he just always felt that he needed to
be the person that needed to protect his
mom at some crazy point part so he just
needed to get stronger
wow
wow that's that's a reason and then he
also became a really funny guy too yeah
to please everybody
that's who genuinely who he is deep down
inside you know he's not like a
man you know like you know oh yeah and
then he just did that to
because that's even a virtuous kind of
reason why he wanted to get big it's
like i want to get big to protect my mom
not like i want to get big to beat the
[ __ ] out of my dad because he made me
feel like a [ __ ] that's why he gets so
good at painting
oh he's a good painter yeah but he does
everything i swear to god he has so much
time he he's a painter too he's really
good because he's uh he played in the
nfl too right yeah did he yeah yeah dude
he can multi-talented he can do photo
realistic art really
maybe because he watches a lot of porn
pull up any one of his paintings
you're going to be so impressed you'll
be like what the hell is painting i want
to know what happened like did they get
his dad like
you know did he get him was there a
revenge some sort of like
like separate them from the mom or
something i don't know what are they
still together look okay so
this is for example one of his paintings
what
wow holy [ __ ]
that [ __ ] looks like a real [ __ ]
becket card dude
why would you ever paint a charger ever
wow
you said you played college or nfl
i don't know maybe he was a charger i
know there's no way he's too cool he's
too cool to be here
that means like you don't know what a
charger is that's correct oh okay oh
it's a football team okay
it's it's a name for a referee um so
he said about his dad it's for it's at
the wedding there's like the table
placement it's a charger
what any football team after it's true
look it up
he said about his father that his father
was too big i mean it was one of those
things where i felt helpless i felt 100
like i was so small i just always felt
tiny i remember just looking at his
hands and they were big giant calloused
hands he's big as [ __ ] though
but but at that time he was like he felt
tiny his dad must be i wonder massive to
them like genetically he said he was
huge he said he would look at his dad
and find a giant cow's hands and the way
he'd walk around the house you just hear
boom boom boom you know it was a drama
he was just saying the venga boys
boom boom boom
magic
it's a different song that works too
boom boom boom i want you in my room and
we can be together
that one right boom boom
boom socks
i think i was at a chinese restaurant
while they were playing that
i think i was on an airplane and an
asian lady behind me was playing on a
little boombox oh yeah i don't know why
asian people just love them i heard his
passion lady was doing that yes
legit very out of character from any
asian
i was on about this one
i was on a plane this little this little
lady was playing like music like that
the whole time on a little boombox just
loud just like loud yeah and that song
no i this song's like that yeah oh okay
i was like just that the whole time in
that shot in that genre
based on those songs can you pull up a
young terry crews photo i want to see
how smaller he was
let's see the dad the dad came to fit in
the photo frame just like part of a
torso let's see let's see
it's one of it's like those things you
never see the face he's [ __ ] huge
he's huge still jack man
okay so i'm guessing
photo of him as a smaller dude looks
like a guy who's like i can't jack off
today we gotta lift
but it's like he had time to lift paint
jack off dude and it's like professional
football i know and he's a really good
dancer and he's super down to earth
he's honestly good on tv too
whoa
and he was a basketball player too what
the [ __ ] i think he's like
i think he was a juggler
[Laughter]
you can't hear the whistle theme when
he's like able to grip the whole
basketball like that dude how old is
terry crews
i think 53 you said right 53. if you're
listening to yourself in your own
article you would have known it let's
say 53 yeah
it's [ __ ] 4 30 p.m that was like the
first time you actually kind of roasted
me today i always listen to you i just
said every single word losing your edge
bro
news source and i'm so
[ __ ] disappointed right now that you
would make facts like [ __ ] up like
you would make facts [ __ ] up [ __ ] up on
your face you will make [ __ ] [ __ ] up you
mix that [ __ ] up man
why do you make that [ __ ] out you gotta
fake [ __ ] up that's kind of brand new
that's kind of what we do
a noodle salesman to [ __ ] host the
show
oh by the way by the way they do have a
new spicy one spicy there you go what's
your review on it i'll be very honest i
don't like it
we just got them today we're going to
try them today
we're
[Laughter]
i'll tell you guys exactly what i think
about this product
when the cameras are not rolling hold on
hold on shadow style what the hell does
that mean no one knows it's shadowless
it's like it's like the pokemon card
shadow jutsu no one knows what's
happening have you ever tried to like
innovate something once
i like it's yoshi's straight up are you
just what does that mean
are you just another blue ranger well
you don't know you don't know what
shadows taste like what's the matter
with you
no legit
legit kenji bang it's been cut that's
what's the best i like it it's great
it's the new cut it's great that's good
it's good that's why
i'm just scared everywhere this but i'm
excited to have the spice one and it's a
new sauce i'm excited do you find it
spicy i have to ask you yes this one's
actually this is spicy okay i'm excited
though i'm excited i'm a big fan of the
kitchen the macros are great it's all of
the like the red oil from the packet
into it
yikes is it spicy enough to make steve
go oh that's kind of spicy i think so he
likes spices i'm excited do you think
they could do a spicy noodle challenge
with your spicy level spicy no no it's
not one of those that's like supposed to
[ __ ] destroy you
supposed to alienate normally most
people are still going to enjoy it
you're not supposed to take the next day
off work
it's not a valid reason did not come to
work most noodles you don't get no
protein you know what i mean i want to
get a viral video of a child licking the
spicy sauce and crying
that's where you usually get [ __ ] that
would go viral
that would go viral i can only do 90 a
day
actually any publicity is good publicity
right that's a good view that's a good
view to have especially jared from
subway he could tell you that
even yoshi going shadow style what the
hell is that that's really good
for sure
hold it up hold it up yoshi and go
oh enough to kiss
yeah
before i heard this whole thing i should
have that's enough for kissing kids aged
noodles
air dried never fried okay
that's what anthony wanted and
certifiably old enough for no saturated
fat or trans fat which is very important
ageless
let's not marry those two brands by the
way how does it always go there what by
the way you can't just keep these
forever these are perishable yeah but
they are old enough for kisses
you